[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHANIE WONG: Hey, everyone.
It's Stephanie Wong, and
today is a very special day
because I'm sure you are
all going to recognize
who I'm bringing on.
If you have seen that networking
102, 102, 3, 4, and 5,
you have learned Google
Cloud's networking fundamentals
from our very own
specialist, Ryan Przbyl.
And he's here today
to discuss something
that's been top of
mind lately for him
around enterprise
networking in the Cloud
and how that's all changing.
So Ryan, welcome to the show.
And you have been itching
to talk about this
and get the word out.
But before we dive in, tell us
a little bit about your role
and some of the
conversations that you've
been having with your
customers around networking.
RYAN PRZBYL: Sure
thing, Stephanie.
I definitely think that's
an interesting topic on how
the conversations are changing.
So my role at Google--
some you know from
the previous videos.
I and my team are network
subject matter experts
for Cloud.
So we work with sales teams.
And we spend pretty much
my entire day talking
about networking either
with customers, with product
managers, or with
some of our tech
leads on the engineering side.
So that's a little
bit my background.
Prior to Google, though,
I think it's interesting,
though, that I was a very
traditional network engineering
guy.
So I worked for a
large telco company.
And I dealt with
the lower layers
of the stack, like I say,
very traditional networking.
So what I'm going to talk
about today is something
of a functional shift
for myself in addition
to the customers, which is why
I thought it was interesting,
because it definitely
has me thinking
a little bit differently
about how we build things
and how the Cloud is
evolving from, say, the way
we were having
conversations with customers
just even a few years ago.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
And you've referred to
this before as network
versus service-oriented model.
And that's the mentality
shift that has to happen.
So why has this suddenly
become so front and center
for you and your customers?
RYAN PRZBYL: Yeah.
So this is kind of
what I was mentioning,
where I see the conversation
itself changing.
There's two types
of conversations
I find myself having with
customers these days.
So when I talk about that
network-centric model, what
I'm really talking
about is, think
about how we've built
traditional data
centers for the past
20, 30 years that we've
been building these things.
It's very network-centric.
And what I mean by that is we're
dealing with a lot of routing,
we're dealing with a lot
of security elements.
Typically, I see this with
very large enterprises, people
that have tons of applications.
As an example, I worked
with one customer
who wanted to migrate 10,000
applications into GCP.
It's a very monumental task.
And one of the things
that we always look at
is, how can we make it very easy
for the customer to migrate in?
And a lot of times-- we use
the term forklifted right.
It's sort of taking their
data center environment
and replicating in the Cloud.
Now, we never want to do an
apples to apples replication.
We want to maybe
change some things
and take advantage
of some of the things
that Cloud brings to the table.
But when I say like
networking-centric
architectures and
network-centric conversations,
it's all about that.
How do I manipulate routes?
How do I build this
infrastructure?
And a lot of times,
the customers
don't even really-- because
there are so many applications
or they don't really deal
with the application teams,
it's really infrastructure
engineering teams,
they don't even know what's
going to come into the Cloud.
Now, the other conversation
I think we have
and when I use the term
service-centric model,
I typically see
this with customers
that were born in the Cloud
or are relatively new.
They're not dealing with a whole
ton of monolithic applications
on the back side.
They are applications
that have been built using
microservice architectures.
And we're talking a
lot about services,
less about networking.
It's not that networking
doesn't exist.
It's just the focus isn't
so much on networking,
more on services
and how services
operate in the environment.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
And this is something that
I bring up all the time
in terms of different
concepts in the Cloud.
And it seems like we're moving
towards this trend of higher
level of abstractions, whether
we're talking about networking
or we're talking
about virtualization.
So you've talked about
larger enterprises
with these
network-oriented teams.
What's the starting
point for them
versus a smaller company that
might be starting already more
Cloud native?
RYAN PRZBYL: Yeah.
So I think when we talk about
these larger customers--
I mentioned earlier data center.
We use a term like DCT,
Data Center Transformation.
And this is where
we're typically
working with these customers
who own their own data centers.
And quite frankly,
if you're a retailer
or you're in some other
business that is not networking,
running a data center is
not your core business.
So it's kind of like
these companies are
like, hey, I have to be an
expert in running a data
center, yet that's
not my core business.
I am a retailer
selling a product.
But networking and
all the stuff that
goes around operating
your business
is such a big aspect
of the business
that they're running
their own data centers.
So when we're talking with those
customers a lot, it's about,
how do they operate
that center today?
And how do we create, again,
not the same exact model--
but how do we take a lot of
those networking constructs
and give them those same
constructs in the Cloud
so that they can move a
lot of these applications?
One of the challenges
that we have
is when we're moving these
applications, we're trying to--
I don't want to say minimize
the amount of changes.
But you can imagine if
you're a company who's
used to operating a
data center and you're
forced to move
10,000 applications,
you don't want to make a
ton of changes to things
because the more stuff
you're migrating,
the more things that can
break and not work and make
your Cloud journey more painful.
So when I think
about how we talk
about a lot of
these conversations,
it's really in the
framework of, help
me understand how your data
center is operating today.
When we're dealing with more
of a Cloud native company
or a company that was
born in the last few years
and has really developed
applications very differently,
they're not dealing with
10,000 applications that
have been built
over the 30 years,
they don't operate
a data center.
Just as an example, this
is a kind of a funny story.
I talked with a customer
who introduced me
to their network engineers.
And their network
engineers told me,
I've never configured a router.
I don't really know a whole
lot about how routing works.
Yet these are their
network engineers.
But because they're
not dealing with a lot
of these antiquated
older constructs,
they weren't familiar with them.
And they weren't as
concerned about them.
So the conversations,
again, were very different.
It was more about,
this is the service.
This is how the service
actually operates.
How do I actually build
this in the environment?
And like I said, we
weren't really getting
into all these complex details
about creating routing domains
and overlaying very complex
security policy over that.
A lot of that stuff comes
from just legacy stuff
and the way customers
have thought
about their data center.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
And I think traditionally,
network architects
and engineers were the ones
who were handling things
like routing and when
they were physical things.
And so it seemed
like before, they
were the ones who were
handling this while
not having as much visibility
into what application
developers were doing.
And it kind of reminds me of how
things are starting to change.
Even when it comes to
DevOps culture for example,
there's more relationship
between developers
and operators.
So do you see that
happening with networking
and the application developers?
Or is it still somewhat
of a black box architects,
and will it continue
to be like that?
RYAN PRZBYL: Yeah.
I definitely think a lot of
customers still very much--
I'm going to use the term
separation of church and state.
I work with a very large
company out on the West Coast.
And we work with their
entire engineering team.
And just as a case
in point, they
don't even know what
applications are going
to come into the environment.
So they build everything as
a hybrid Cloud environment
where they present
to their developers
and application teams
like, here's what
services are available in GCP.
But here's what services are
available at other clouds.
And they leave it up to
the application teams
to decide where
they want to deploy.
So it could be in GCP.
Or it could be one
of our competitors.
And this is becoming
more and more common
too where people are wanting
to embrace a multi-Cloud sort
of environment.
So they're trying to
create kind of an apples
to apples comparison between
these different clouds
and the data center that
they run on prem so that when
an application team comes in
to run something in the Cloud,
they don't really care where
it runs, whether it runs
in their data center on
prem, whether it runs in GCP,
or runs in one of
our competitors.
They leave that up to
the application team
to decide what is the
best environment for them.
So in that case, they are in
some ways completely isolated.
And it makes it really
interesting because when
we talk to them about, what is
the future workload look like
and how do you plan the stuff?
One, they don't even know.
And two, I say this
kind of loosely,
but they don't really care.
It's kind of like, we just
build the infrastructure
and we present all
these capabilities
to our internal business units,
and they make all the decisions
around this stuff.
STEPHANIE WONG: Do you think
that that's the case for Cloud
too?
Because I'm imagining an
application developer that
is working with, let's
say, Google Cloud.
They do have to somewhat have
a fundamental understanding
of how VPCs work
and somewhat know
the operational aspects of it.
Or do you still
think it is fairly
segregated in that aspect?
RYAN PRZBYL: Again,
I think it depends
on the size of the organization.
The really big
organizations with--
let's say you have 500
traditional network
engineers working for you.
It's still a very
segregated conversation.
And then I would
also say, depending
on how we build
the infrastructure,
the developers don't
always really even
have to have a lot of
knowledge about the underlying
infrastructure.
If the team that we work
with does it the right way
and they're
automating everything
and they're using
a lot of the tools
that we give them
and recommend, they
can deploy the environment very
quickly and very seamlessly.
And then the developers
can come along
and everything is completely
transparent to them.
They can build VMs.
They can do what developers
want to do and not
have to worry about all of
the infrastructure components.
So again, if you
kind of do it right,
you can have the
infrastructure team still
being very walled off and have
the development team come in
and do their work.
But again, to your point,
the newer companies
that we deal with--
when I say newer,
I think about companies
that are doing
service offerings in the Cloud.
Maybe that's their
main business.
A lot of times their
network engineers
are definitely a
lot more attached
at the hip with the developers
and with the services that
are running because
they need to be
running just a handful
of services in the Cloud
environment.
It's not like I said
before, an engineering
team that's like, we
have 10,000 applications.
They can't be like
attached at the hip
with 10,000 different
developers who are working
on all of this different stuff.
It's just impossible.
So I think a lot
of your question
kind of depends on, how
big it is the organization
and how much--
we use the term technical debt.
But how much
baggage do they have
that they're trying to move
into their Cloud environment?
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
And so let's drill down
on that a little bit
because we're talking about
companies of varying sizes,
backgrounds, network
topology sizes.
So how does the path
differ for a company that
does have 10,000
applications and more
traditional networking complex
topology versus a company that
is Cloud native, has a
service in the Cloud already,
and they can kind of get up
and running more quickly there?
RYAN PRZBYL: Yeah.
So I think the path--
and I'm going to go back
in history a little bit.
So four to five
years ago, I would
say a lot of
conversations were, we
want to dabble with the Cloud.
We want to move some
applications in,
nothing business critical.
I see a lot of the
big organizations that
are still trying to onboard.
They're still kind
of in that model.
Let's try to rebuild as
much of the data center
as we can in the Cloud.
And I use the term--
I like fruit.
Call it apples to apples
or apples to oranges.
An apple is round and maybe red.
And an orange is round
but maybe orange.
We're trying to get
them to maybe go
from apples to oranges.
We don't want to get them to
go from apples to cherries.
That's a very different fruit.
It's much smaller, a
complete different color.
Forgive my high-level
analogy there, but hopefully
that makes sense.
We want them to take some
advantages of the Cloud,
but asking them to make
too much of a change
is just more than some of these
large enterprises can bite off.
You don't want to set
yourself on a path
to migrate 10,000
things and then find out
you changed so many
things when you migrated
to Cloud that have the
applications don't work,
they're broken.
You can create a lot of
operational challenges
for yourself.
And that's where
our team comes in.
We're trying to
really understand--
while we're building
networks, we're
trying to understand, what
are the applications that run
on top of all of this stuff?
Because we don't just
build networks in a vacuum.
We build them to
support applications.
But we also understand we're not
just dealing with technology.
I can build all sorts of
networks in the Cloud.
But you've got things
like operational models.
There might be a team of 500
operational engineers who
have to operate this
thing every day.
And if they operate a
certain type of network,
that's what they're
used to dealing with.
And if I take that network and
completely change it too much,
well, they got to
retrain 500 people.
Their tools that they
use for monitoring
might have to change.
So it's not just
about the technology
and how we're using it, but
you've got to really consider
the applications
that we're moving,
the operational models,
the business structure
that the customer uses.
And again, this is where
things get really complex
with these large enterprises.
They're businesses.
They may have 30
different business units
that all operate in
a very specific way.
If they change things too
much and the business units
can't operate in
that same way, that
can be very problematic
for their business.
So it's very interesting working
with these large enterprises
because it's not purely a
technology conversation.
We're trying to build
the right network,
but we're trying to look at
all these different lenses
to build the right network for
the customer that allows them
to migrate in the Cloud,
capitalize on some of what
the Cloud brings to
them, but not create
so much change that it's
going to be completely
disruptive for them.
And that's where I think
the conversation is really
interesting between the service
model and the architecture
model.
The service model can be
a very different change
to start thinking about--
think about this way.
If you're a network engineer and
you're dealing with networking
and routing and all of a
sudden they ask you to, say,
don't be so
concerned about that.
Be concerned more with how
your service is functioning.
They're like, well, I've never
thought about my service.
I've never really thought
about that before.
I just built the infrastructure
and the service teams
come in and use it.
And I'm saying, no, no, no.
We're going to do a
paradigm shift here.
That can be a lot for
a company to bite off.
So even though I think
that's the future--
a lot of companies
are going that way.
And that's even how Google runs.
When you look at Google as
a company, we run services.
We run Gmail.
We run Search.
We run YouTube.
While we have a very
complex underlying network,
that's not what we
focus on every day.
We focus on the service.
Is the service up?
Is the service running?
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
And this path that
we're talking about
involves responsibility
both from the Cloud provider
and the customer,
as you're saying.
It's a paradigm shift for both.
So when we're talking about
building a bridge between going
from apples to oranges, what
is actually being abstracted
and handled by a
provider like Google
Cloud in a
service-oriented model?
RYAN PRZBYL: Yeah, it's
a really good question.
So if you look at a
traditional networking model
and I have a bunch of different
applications that are running,
just as an example,
typically you were saying,
this application is
running over here,
and this application
is running over here,
and the two need
to talk together.
So what is the route
to get between them?
And what sort of functionality,
what sort of security parameter
do I have to overlay
on the top of it?
But generally speaking,
we're dealing with layer 3
and 4 connectivity
with a security
bend to it at some level.
When you start to talk
about service networking,
let me talk about one
particular product.
We talk about private service
connect, or PSC as we call it.
PSC is designed to be what we
would-- the term I would use
is a service endpoint.
So think about it as an endpoint
that you put into your network
that front ends a service.
And that could be a
service you're consuming
from some outside entity.
It could be a service
that you're consuming
from another business unit.
But it abstracts a
lot of things for you
and changes the
conversation to, how do I
route between here and here?
It's kind of just, how do
I get to the end point?
But once it gets
to the endpoint,
PSC does a lot of things under
the covers that you don't see.
It handles the
routing to that other,
what we call the service
producer, which, again, could
be something that
lives completely
outside of your organization.
Could be a third party
company that you're
buying a service from.
So how do you route
to that company?
How do you handle
overlapping IP space?
If you're a traditional
network engineer
and you're looking at
this, you're kind of going,
OK, I've got this IP space
here and this IP space here
and I have to manage
it in some way
or I have to control
NADing between them,
and I'm going to install this
device that's going to do this.
Again, very network-centric
conversation.
You introduce PSC to
the mix, and it's like,
just route it to the
end point and Google
will manage everything else.
We'll manage the routing to
somebody else in somebody
else's environment completely.
We'll handle all the NADing
and all of that stuff for you
so you don't have
to worry about it.
So again, it just
becomes this endpoint
that sits in your network
that front ends the service.
And we're looking at doing
that even with Google APIs
and Google Services where you
can put a PSC endpoint in place
to front end those APIs.
And you can control it
a little bit different.
Now, one of the
things I would say
is if you're a
traditional network team
and you're like,
well, OK, what happens
when the service doesn't work?
How do I troubleshoot this?
Because Google is managing
a bunch of the [INAUDIBLE]
for you, Google's managing
some of the routing,
Google's managing some
NADing under the covers,
you kind of lose visibility
to some of that stuff.
And if you're thinking for a
very network-centric mindset,
it kind of causes this
knee jerk reaction
to say like, OK, as a network
engineer myself, somebody who's
been in the situation
of like, is it
the network that's
causing the problem,
the network engineers are always
trying to clear the network
and say it's not the network.
And you need
visibility end to end.
But with something like PSC--
and I'm not saying
PSC is a bad thing,
but once it hits that point, you
kind of lose visibility to it.
Is it something on
the other side that's
not working that you can see?
Is it the service producer
that's having a problem?
At the end of the day,
what really matters is
the service is down.
But how you troubleshoot
it and how you
approach it is very different.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
And I can understand hesitation
around relinquishing control
or visibility so that you can
troubleshoot and actually find
root of cause.
And we'll talk more about
this later about some
of the network intelligence
that we provide for visibility,
but I do want to highlight
a point that you were making
earlier about not needing to
completely shift your existing
model to the Cloud when
it doesn't make sense.
And it kind of reminds me
of what we tell customers
about microservice
migration, people
who are moving from
virtual machines
into more of a
containerised environment.
You should actually
move what makes sense.
And you don't
necessarily need to do
a complete decoupling
or re-architecture.
Are you seeing most companies
using Cloud native apps
to adopt this
service-oriented model?
Or is there actually
an opportunity
to use traditional more
hefty applications built
on complex networking
models and shift that
to a service-oriented model?
RYAN PRZBYL: So it's a
really good question.
I think the answer is you can.
So if you have these big
monolithic applications--
and we do talk to
customers about this--
you can spend time to
re-architect the application.
The question is, do you want to?
So if it's an
application that is going
to be business critical
for the next 20 years
and you're wanting to move into
more of a service-centric model
and you want to break it
down into microservices
so you can make changes to
small parts of the application
without trying to overhaul
the whole thing, sure.
It may make sense
for you to do that.
But think about it
from this perspective.
You have a working application.
Maybe it doesn't really
work with the service level
constructs.
It's not set up
as a microservice.
It is just this big monolithic
thing that you want to move.
We move those things all the
time, and they work just fine.
So if you're a business
leader in that company
and you can migrate that
application into the Cloud,
a lot of times it's, just do
it and don't spend the time
and the resources to
re-architect the whole thing
because a lot of
these applications--
they're not going
to be something
you're in use for 20 years.
They're going to change.
So again, I'll go back to
that term technical debt.
You could move a very
large application
in and it brings with
it some technical debt.
You could spend a
lot of time and money
trying to fix a
lot of that stuff.
Or you can just
take the approach
of, I know in five years that
application is going to go away
anyways, so I don't want to
spend the time and the money
to refactor, re-architect
the application
into a new construct.
I just know when we build the
next one or whatever that next
application is for that
piece of my business--
maybe it's your
HR as an example--
it's going to be more
Cloud native in the future.
Maybe we're going to go and
use Software-as-a-Service from
somebody else, and this is going
to be a service that's running
in the Cloud.
And maybe that company is going
to use PSC, as an example,
to basically put an endpoint
into my network that basically
means my entire monolithic
application that I use today is
going to go away in five
years because I'm now using
Software-as-a-Service
through some other company.
So when you think about
that, does it really
make sense to spend the time
and the effort to do it?
In a lot of cases, my point
of view is it doesn't.
We can make it work in
the Cloud most times.
So let's make it work, and
let's just move on and just
acknowledge that there's
technical debt there
and it maybe is not the optimal
architecture for what you want.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
And I think companies
probably are on the same page,
as you not wanting to reinvest
a whole lot of upfront capital
just to change the things
that are already working.
And as we know,
architectural changes
beget new security reviews and
a lot of downstream effects.
So do you have any stories
of customers or people
you've worked with that have
had to go through this process?
RYAN PRZBYL: Yeah.
So interesting enough, I was
working with one customer.
And one of the things people
have to understand about Cloud
is it's a constantly
evolving model.
And I think we'll talk about
this in the next segment
that we're going to do.
It's not like your
traditional data center.
Things change much
faster in the Cloud.
And we'll talk about
that, of the why.
But a lot of enterprises-- to
change their architecture--
I actually had a very
senior architect kind
of yelling at me on the
phone and kind of saying,
it's great that Google can
shift on the fly like that.
But every time we make
architectural changes,
they have to go through
security reviews.
There's all of this red
tape that has to be done.
So when we think about--
with this particular
customer, I was
like, this is the way the
architecture will look today.
In 6 months or 12
months, there's
all these other features are
going to come down the pipe.
And this is how I would
change it in the future.
And that's where it was creating
this really tough rub to say,
yeah, but for me to implement
those changes is going
to take me 6 to 12
months because I
have to have security
reviews, I have
to have architecture reviews.
So there was all
this red tape that
comes around with making
these changes to customers.
So while we're always saying
like, the Cloud is constantly
evolving, you want to
constantly be changing,
we also have to be
cognizant that Google
can change on a dime.
This is the way
Google was built.
But not all enterprises
can do that.
And that's OK.
I think we as a
company just have
to be cognizant that not
everybody operates at Google.
And I say it's kind
of a funny story
because literally they
were yelling at me saying,
I have to go back to
enterprise 101 school
because that's not
how enterprises work.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
Right.
And I do want to dig into
this a lot more, Ryan,
but we're going to save some
of this for the next segment,
as you mentioned.
And I want to dive
a little bit more
into that operational shift and
what Google Cloud specifically
is doing to build
a bridge to get
people to have a stepping stone
into a service-oriented model.
So Ryan, thank you so
much for joining today.
And for everybody
else, stay tuned.
We're going to come out with
another episode shortly.
RYAN PRZBYL: Thanks for
having me, Stephanie.
[MUSIC PLAYING]